Welcome students to
the Pharmacology of the
Disease-Modifying
Antirheumatic Drugs.
This is the second
part. We'll be talking
about some more oral
conventional DMARDs,
the biologics, and the
targeted small molecule
synthetic DMARDs.
These are also oral.
Dr. Goldstein speaking.
Please contact
me. I'd love
to talk pharmacology
with you.
learning objectives
these are the same as
last time as for part
one because this really
is just one lecture
in two hours or so
preparation and links
if you wish to use them
I'm going to begin
this time with an
introductory case
vignette about Justine.
Justine is a 45
-year-old female
diagnosed with
moderately to severely
active rheumatoid
arthritis.
The rheumatologist
discusses
early aggressive
therapy with her.
She agrees to oral
triple therapy with
glucocorticoid bridging.
What medications
will Justine be receiving
for RA treatment?
What monitoring
for adverse effects
should be done
relative to each drug?
If you'd like to
pause, think about
it, look ahead,
see what you come
up with, and here
are the answers.
What I want to point out
here is the monitoring.
Notice please that
the monitoring is
related to the potential
adverse effects
and patient's renal
function. It's all
about patient safety,
safety, safety.
The drugs are associated
with potentially
serious adverse
effects. Most people
tolerate them
quite well, and I'm
talking about the
whole group of DMARDs.
But these serious adverse
effects can occur,
but they can be
mitigated, which is why
we look out for them,
hence the monitoring.
We'll begin with
sulfasalazine.
We talked about
prednisone
and methotrexate
in part one.
Sulfosalazine is
a continuation of
the conventional
DMARDs, the orals.
Sulfosalazine is an
interesting molecule.
It's composed
of two parts.
I put mesalamine
on this side,
sulfapyridine on
On this side, here
is the mesalamine
part, it is
also called 5
-aminosalicylic acid.
Salicylic acid,
you may recall,
is the other
name for aspirin.
On this side is
sulfapyridine.
Sulfapyridine is
a sulfonamide.
We talked about
the sulfonamide
antibiotics. It's
in the same class.
However, sulfapyridine
does not have
very good anti
-infective properties.
These two components
are connected
by this so-called
azo linkage.
When this bond
is broken, then
we get these
two components.
And I'll go into details
on this on the
next slide.
the azole linkage is
cleaved by enteric
bacteria by the
bacteria in our gut
microbiome those
organisms that have
this so-called azole
reductase enzyme
then releasing
sulfapyridine which is
thought to be the
active component for
the treatment of
rheumatoid arthritis.
And this other part,
mesalamine, which
really stays in the
gut. Very little
absorption of this
product when it is carried
down to the distal
ileum as a component
of sulfasalazine.
So because the
enteric bacterial
enzymes are cleaving this
linkage, it's happening
later on in the
gut, right there at
the juxtaposition
between the distal
ileum and the colon.
So the mesalamine is
not absorbed to any
significant extent. Now,
it's this mesalamine
that is actually the
active component for
the treatment of
inflammatory bowel disease,
but that's not what
we're talking about
today. We're talking
about the systemic
absorption of sulfasalazine
and sulfapyridine.
speaking of which the
sulfasalazine itself
the whole molecule
it has very low
bioavailability however
the sulfapyridine
has about 60%
bioavailability as you can
see that is certainly
a significant
amount for producing
a therapeutic effect
sulfapyridine like
other sulfonamides is
highly albumin bound
and can displace
other drugs other
products whether it's a
drug or an endogenous
molecule that is
located with that does
attach to albumin.
Both of these
components, sulfapyridine
and the whole
sulfasalazine,
can achieve adequate
concentration in
synovial fluid.
And what is adequate
concentration?
That means high
enough concentration
in there to produce
its anti-inflammatory
effect in rheumatoid
arthritis.
Sulfapyridine undergoes
hepatic acetylation,
just like the
other sulfonamides.
Slow acetylators
may have an
increased risk
of toxicity, just
like the other
sulfonamides.
the enzyme involved is n
-a-t-2 n-acetyltransferase
type 2 this is
one of the enzymes
that was introduced
to you in foundations
of medicine renal
excretion of metabolites
and unchanged drug
here we have the half
-lives of fast acetyl
later slow acetylators
and everybody else
is rather in between.
Onset. We talked about
onset of action with
methotrexate being in
the neighborhood of
a month and with
sulfasalazine it's anywhere
from six weeks to
three months so it
takes quite a bit longer
time for actually I
put onset but But
actually, it's for the
anti-rheumatic effect
to be fully available.
Well, what's
the mechanism?
Here's your takeaway.
Unknown.
It's just not clear
how self-aparidine,
if that is indeed
the active component,
how it reduces
inflammation. So we'll
talk about what is
known. And these are
based on in vitro
and in vivo studies.
Are these observed
actions the
reason why the
drug is effective
in rheumatoid arthritis?
Well, one can
only postulate.
So this is what's known.
The drug will suppress
T cell responses,
inhibit B cell
proliferation. so we have
this is our
lymphocytic actions or
cellular actions and by
doing this these jobs
the cytokine release
will be suppressed
and we see a reduction
so this is how we
can follow the disease
activity a reduction
in rheumatoid factor
in RA patients
well how efficacious
is it well it is a
DMARD it follows it
fits right into the
definition it reduces
radiologic disease
progression and it
has other therapeutic
benefits it can be used
as monotherapy however
combination is more
effective so it's
frequently used together
with mesotrexate
and hydroxychloroquine
may be added to it.
So the two of them
is double therapy
and the three of them is
obviously triple therapy.
Those are the
industry terms.
Sulfothalazine does
appear to be safe during
pregnancy and it is
approved for juvenile
type of arthritis and
ulcerative colitis.
That's its
other indication
that I mentioned earlier.
Adverse effects. Well, I
read that approximately
45% or so patients
will discontinue
the drug because of
these common adverse
effects, especially
headache and GI effects.
The drug can
also cause rash.
Oligospermia, which
is reversible, meaning
that once the drug
is stopped, the
normal function and
production will return.
And hemolytic anemia
in patients with G6PD.
Well, this is a
sulfonamide thing.
Sulfonamides are
oxidative. They can
cause hemolysis in
patients with G6PD.
It seems, based on
observation over all
these many decades,
that sulfasalazine
really has a low
tendency to cause it. But
there may be people,
especially with
severe G6PD deficiency,
who would experience
hemolytic anemia
with sulfasalazine.
And there are other
drugs that can be
given in order to
avoid that possibility.
Drug interactions.
Well, this is actually
a drug-food interaction,
but it fits here.
Sulfosalazine impairs
folic acid absorption.
The recommendation
is for patients to
take folic acid
supplementation every day.
And if the patient
is pregnant or
certainly planning
on becoming pregnant,
then a higher dose of
folic acid is strongly
recommended. And
then, as with all
drugs, drugs with the
same adverse effects
causes additive
adverse effects. So,
other drugs that
cause GI effects are
additive together with
the sulfasalazine,
just to give
you an example.
Now, we must not forget
about these potential
life-threatening
toxicities. Fortunately,
they're very rare,
but they do occur, and
we need to be vigilant
in monitoring for
them. These are delayed
hypersensitivity
reactions, serious
cutaneous adverse effects,
severe cutaneous
adverse effects, which
of course has its own
acronym. These are
Stevens-Johnson
Syndrome, Toxic Epidermal
Necrolysis, and Drug
Reaction with Eosinophilia
and Systemic
Symptoms. Systemic
Symptoms. That means
the organs are involved.
Of course, that
acronym is DRESS.
Liver,
lungs,
kidneys, and blood cells.
Absolutely, the patient
should be cautioned,
advised, and family
members to stop
taking the drug at
the very first sign of
rash and to call the
rheumatologist, and
if it's severe, to
get to the emergency
department and to report
thoroughly all the
medications that that
patient is taking.
This is Urticaria here
on this left hand.
These big, these
are welts that
are so close together,
they look like
one big thing.
Here's one welt.
These are really big,
and they can be itchy.
So this is
urticaria, typical
of an allergic reaction.
Toxic epidermal
necrolysis of
the face. The
skin is just
lifting up. And
here on the leg.
Okay, hydroxychloroquine
now. Chloroquine also.
Hydroxychloroquine
is very closely
structurally related
on this figure.
It's very difficult
to see the difference.
It's just got
this hydroxyl
group here on
this chloroquine.
But I put a star on
the hydroxychloroquine
because it is the
most frequently
used. Both are
equally efficacious.
It seems that
hydroxychloroquine has
better GI tolerance
than chloroquine,
and it may cause
less ocular toxicity.
that needs to be
monitored, of course.
Rapid complete
absorption,
moderate plasma
protein binding,
extensively sequestered
in tissues. Look at this.
Humongous volume
of distribution.
And that's because
it attaches to the
macromolecules in so many
tissues, including the
melanin-containing
tissues, eyes, and skin.
It sequesters
in the liver and
the spleen and red
blood cells, the
brain, the heart,
the kidneys,
and white blood
cells, lungs, and that
explains its tremendous
volume of distribution.
The It has extensive
hepatic metabolism.
Chloroquine, which is not
starred, will
inhibit 2D6, and it
is a substrate
of these CYPs.
Renal excretion,
metabolites,
unchanged drug.
Half-life, 30 to 50
days, and that goes back
to the sequestration
in the tissues. It
takes a long time, once
that drug is removed,
for the molecules
to move out of
the tissues and
back into the
bloodstream and
eventually out.
Onset six weeks to
three months, also
slow, and this is
actually full RA effect.
So what's going
on with this drug?
Well,
hydroxychloroquine and
chloroquine are
anti-malarial drugs.
That's what they
were developed for.
And if the malaria
is susceptible,
they're very
effective. Of course,
there's a lot of
resistance in malaria.
So when it comes
to inflammatory and
autoimmune diseases, we
really don't know for
sure what the mechanism
is. So this is,
like we said with
sulfasalazine, this is
what's been observed.
the drugs do
concentrate within the
acidic vesicles they do
increase the pH of
the lysosomal and
endosomal compartments
and this is because
they are weak bases
they by so doing they
may interfere with
the function of those
compartments. It
appears that they
suppress the T cell
responses, decrease
leukocyte chemotaxis,
stabilize the enzymes,
lysosomal enzymes,
which means
they're not
doing their job,
inhibit DNA and
RNA synthesis, and
trap free radicals.
Okay, great.
They do this apparently
by accumulating
within the white
blood cells.
What do we use it
for? Monotherapy
for mild, only mild RA.
Hydroxychloroquine and
chloroquine are rather
weak anti and have
really rather weak
anti-inflammatory
effects in these diseases
if you if you can call
it that really it's
not like an NSAID and
but most frequently
they're used together
with mesotrexate or
sulfasalazine. That's
just the most frequent.
You may see other
uses when you are in
clinical rotations or
if you're when you're
seeing patients as a
practicing physician.
Well, here we go with
the adverse effects.
GI upset, that's
getting to be
rather similar among
them all, nausea,
vomiting,
cramping, diarrhea,
headache.
Serious, again, very
rare, thankfully.
Most people tolerate
the drug pretty
well, but skin
reactions can occur. The
drug does get into
the CNS. Some patients
who are susceptible
may experience CNS
effects, even
psychosis and seizures.
Muscle weakness.
Retinal damage.
Remember we talked
about melanin
and melanin is
in the retina.
And also QT interval
prolongation.
Generally not a problem
except for those
who are at risk.
So ocular effects,
this retinopathy,
which unfortunately
can be irreversible,
and corneal deposits,
which appear
to be reversible.
So what do we do?
The patient should
be going to the
ophthalmologist and
getting a baseline exam.
So there's a
starting point. Also,
at this time, the
patient can be
screened if the
patient already has
retinopathy or
corneal deposits.
Hydroxychloroquine would
not be a good option.
And then once a year
to follow that up.
Pregnancy and
lactation, well,
seems to be safe
all the way through
and for the
breastfeeding child.
The flunamide now,
flu, see all these
fluorines on here, it
is a prodrug. It
has good absorption,
and it is rapidly
converted by non-enzymatic
conversion to its
active metabolite,
which is called M1,
and it's actually
been given a name,
teraflunamide. and that
teraflunamide itself
is a drug product.
Enterohepatic
circulation.
I put some arrows
here because this
enterohepatic
circulation has clinical
effects that are
important to remember.
First, let's see.
has a very long half
-life, 18 days on average.
So it stays in the
body for a long time.
Loflunamide is
associated with some very
important toxicities.
It's generally well
tolerated, but as we
always say, We have to be
alert for these toxicities.
And in the event
that the patient suffers
a severe toxicity,
the drug needs
to be removed as
rapidly as possible.
Instead of waiting
for, let's say,
20 days just
because it's easy
to multiply by four,
to wait two
months for the
drug to clear,
that's too long.
So what do we do?
Cholestyramine.
Cholestyramine
is something
I've mentioned
briefly before.
It is a resin,
and it stays in
the gut, so it's
not absorbed.
Remember that
teraflunamide
undergoes enterohepatic
circulation,
which is probably
one reason
why the half
-life is so long.
when it comes around
goes through the liver
goes into the gall
platter gets squeezed
in back into the
intestine when the
cholestyramine is there
it's going to grab onto
it so that the leflunamide
is not reabsorbed
and that will rapidly
reduce plasma levels
of the leflunamide
of the teraflunamide
So enterohepatic
circulation,
cholestyramine to
chelate it in the
gut in the event of
severe toxicity or
if the patient wishes
to become pregnant
and the enterohepatic
circulation
is also related to
the long half-life.
Full effect of
laflunamide can occur
in about a month,
up to two months.
What does it do?
Here's the target.
Dihydroorotate
dehydrogenase. This enzyme is
the rate limiting step
in the synthesis of
nucleotides pyrimidines
of the pyrimidines.
Pyrimidines are
essential for
RNA synthesis and
DNA synthesis.
I've indicated them here.
So blocking this enzyme
will reduce pyrimidine
synthesis. And that
in turn will reduce,
inhibit T cell
proliferation and reduces
the production of
autoantibodies by B cells.
So it blocks the pro
-inflammatory effects.
That's basically it.
Antiproliferative, that's
what we're talking
about here,
T-cell and B-cell, and
anti-inflammatory
effects.
Dihydroorotate
dehydrogenase
is blocked by
teraflunamide.
Toxicities.
GI, well, diarrhea is
pretty common. Nausea.
The severe
liver injury is
important to be
monitoring for.
This adverse effect
does have a U.S.
boxed warning on it
because fatalities
have occurred.
Fulminant liver
failure, hepatic
necrosis, cirrhosis.
Got to get that drug
out of the body as
fast as possible if
symptoms and signs
arise. So what are
the risk factors?
Well, a higher dose.
We see that often.
Higher dose dependent
adverse effects. Patients
who already have
liver disease and
concomitant drugs that
can cause liver toxicity.
Oh gosh, here's
methotrexate. We know
methotrexate can
cause liver toxicity.
Bone marrow
suppression. What's
a risk factor?
Oh, methotrexate.
Severe cutaneous
adverse effects.
Again, mechanism
is not clear.
And so lung
toxicity, toxicity,
nerve toxicity,
peripheral neuropathy,
infection, and
what's a risk
factor, history of
methotrexate use.
So monitoring, well,
as with all strong
immunosuppressants, we
look to see if there's
latent tuberculosis,
if the patient
was exposed to
tuberculosis, so we need to
screen for that. We
monitor complete blood
count, so we're
monitoring for this bone
marrow suppression,
signs of infection,
LFTs, liver
function tests for
hepatotoxicity,
and cholestyramine
in the event of
severe toxicity.
That's it.
Pretty straightforward.
Pregnancy
contraindicated.
So now we have
two drugs that are
absolutely contraindicated
in pregnancy,
methotrexate and
liflunamide. It's the
only two that we're
going to be talking
about in terms of
DMARDs that are
absolutely contraindicated
in pregnancy.
There's some that should
be avoided because
not enough information
is available.
But these are
known fetotoxic
embryo-lethal drugs.
This is just a
little mind chart or
whatever showing the
overlapping of effects.
I have a
question for you.
The slide is present on
the video,
obviously. June
is a 28-year-old woman
given a diagnosis
of moderate RA
without features of a
poor prognosis. She's
recently married
and reports that she
and her husband are
planning to start
a family. Which of
the following would
be an appropriate
initial RA monotherapy
for this patient?
Hydroxychloroquine,
leflunamide,
methotrexate, or
sulfasalazine.
Moderate RA without
features of
poor prognosis.
And the second case
is, SJ is a 45-year
-old man who presents
to the ED with
complaints of nausea
and vomiting, lack
of appetite, right
upper quadrant pain,
abdominal distension,
generalized
itching, jaundice,
fatigue, and confusion.
Medical history is
significant for moderate
to severe RA treatment
with an oral CS DMARD.
Demard. Right upper
quadrant tenderness,
hepatomegaly, and
ascites are noted on PE.
Prothrombin time
is prolonged.
Aminotransferase
and bilirubin
levels are elevated.
Those are LFTs.
Prothrombin time shows
increased time
to clotting.
The patient is
admitted for management
of drug-induced acute
liver failure. If
this were a board
exam, that piece of
information would not
be provided. You would
be expected to
figure out what the
problem is, but by
then you'll be able to.
Cholestyramine is
included in the
treatment to accelerate
drug elimination
by preventing
enteropathic circulation
of this RA drug.
What is the drug?
So here are the
answers to both.
So the first one
is sulfasalazine.
It's known to be safe
during pregnancy.
And it will likely
be efficacious
in this moderately
active disease.
Methotrexate and
laflunamide are obviously
contraindicated. And
hydroxychloroquine
is really an
alternative for
patients with mild
rheumatoid arthritis.
And here, obviously,
laflunamide.
I know you all
got that one.
And we're going to
return to Mary's case.
Mary presents to the
rheumatologist for
a three-month evaluation
of her rheumatoid
arthritis treatment.
In the past
month, she experienced
a disease flare
treated with a three
-week course of high
-dose prednisone
followed by dose
tapering and withdrawal
of the glucocorticoid.
She is tolerating
the mesotrexate.
As monotherapy with
mesotrexate alone was
inadequate for controlling
disease activity,
Mary is offered oral
triple therapy or
mesotrexate plus a
biologic DMARD therapy.
Mary opts for the
biologic agent because
therapeutic response
is achieved more
quickly than with
the triple therapy.
She refuses the
intravenous biologic
DMART option and agrees
to add-on therapy
with adalimumab, self
-injected subucanus,
subcutaneously
every other week,
which is covered by
her insurance plan.
Adalimumab is in
what class of drugs,
and these are
mechanism-based classes
which really makes
it easier to remember
them, or to remember
what they do.
What is the intravenous
option that Mary
preferred not to
receive, and what are
other therapy options
for the treatment of
RA resistant to
methotrexate monotherapy?
I invite you to pause and
see if you can
think of them.
Here are the answers.
Adalimumab is a TNF
inhibitor, and the
intravenous TNF
inhibitor is infliximab.
And the other options
are laflunamide, which
we talked about,
alternative to mesotrexate.
It is sometimes given
with mesotrexate
because of the effectiveness
of this combination,
but of course we have
to remember the higher
incidence of toxicity
because mesotrexate
and liflunamide share
the same toxicities.
And mesotrexate
plus abatacept or
tocilizumab, cerulamab
is in the same group,
or tofacitinib and
baricitinib and
upatacitinib are in the
same group, or rituximab.
And we'll talk
about all of these.
The targeted
immunosuppressive agents
are the biologic
DMARDs, which which
specifically target
membrane receptors
and the targeted
small molecule drugs,
which are oral. And
there's only this
one group, the Janus
kinase inhibitors.
Class properties.
Well, the route
of administration
is usually IV or sub-Q.
Those are the
biologics because
they're polypeptides.
so they're
not absorbed by
the GI tract.
The targeted small
molecule agent is oral.
Mechanism of
action? Well, they
target specific
mediators of
inflammation or
receptor proteins.
They're used usually
in combination.
Certain of them may be
used as monotherapy.
And this is all based
on how they were used
in clinical trials. So
that's the information
that was received.
Was it given together
with methotrexate?
Was it given alone?
And then the results
demonstrated
their efficacy.
The adverse effects,
well, infection.
These are very strong
immunosuppressants.
So patients
are at risk for
infection because
the immune system is
suppressed to fight
off the infection.
Lymphoma, so cancer.
bone marrow suppression,
liver injury,
another autoimmune-like
problem, lupus
-like syndrome,
high blood pressure,
heart failure,
immunologic
reactions. These
are drug-specific.
Immunologic
reactions with the
biologics can happen
with any of them
because they are
polypeptides. The
patient should
receive immunizations
at least two weeks
before starting
therapy with an
immunosuppressant.
To give them afterwards,
especially live
attenuated viruses,
can have diminished
efficacy because
the immune system
is suppressed.
and with the attenuated
live vaccines
there's this theoretical
risk that the person
could develop the
infection from the
vaccine. This is really
a theoretical risk,
but we don't want
to forget about it.
Tuberculosis,
hepatitis B virus,
hepatitis C virus,
and PML, which I'll
talk about when I
get to rituximab.
Monitoring depends
on the particular
adverse effects
and basically
that's true
with all drugs.
Pregnancy, well
studies have not
been conducted
by and large.
There are some
that can be used.
Lactation, don't know
the extent to which
the drug is excreted
in breast milk.
And pediatrics, many
of these can be used
for management of
autoimmune diseases
or arthritis in
particular in children.
I can't say often
enough about this
immunosuppression that
occurs with these.
They're strong
immunosuppressants.
we don't use them
with other strong
immunopressants we
do use them with
the conventional
demard they can be
used with mesotrexate
or sulfasalazine or
hydroxychloroquine
infection liver
injury blood pressure
allergic reaction and
so on i'm not going
to dwell on that.
Let's get to the drugs.
Infliximab was
the first one,
the prototype,
still widely used.
This one's IV in
the United States.
Etainercept
and Adalimumab.
These three were
developed first,
infliximab first,
Etainercept, then
Adalimumab, then
the other ones.
This is Iximab,
this is Moomab,
Moomab, Zumab, and
that just indicates
the level of
humanization or human
antibiotic.
This is mousy. This
has more mouse parts.
Okay,
it looks like any
antibiotic antibody.
The Etainercept,
however, is
something called
a fusion protein.
So this was actually
manufactured,
and then it was
at high quantities
by recombinant
technology.
Here's the Cirtilizumab.
It's just this
little piece and then
it's got this
polyethylene glycol
on the end. And
the purpose of this
polyethylene glycol
is pharmacokinetic
unless it stays
around longer.
Here's infliximab.
This is the mouse
part on here.
All right, why TNF
-alpha? Because it
plays an important
role in the
pathophysiology of
rheumatoid arthritis.
It's found in the
synovial fluid.
It's produced by
the monocytes, the
macrophages, the
B cells, T cells,
fibroblasts, and
it promotes the
expression of all of
these pro-inflammatory
cytokines and
other proteins.
So if we inhibit this,
the action of TNF,
then we can inhibit
this part, production
of all of these pro
-inflammatory molecules.
And this little
illustration is here
just to help you
visualize the
actions of TNF in
rheumatoid arthritis
and other
inflammatory diseases.
You don't have
to memorize all
of these different
interleukins.
different proteins
mechanism of action
well these drugs bind
the actual cytokine
TNF alpha they bind
to it when it's
floating around and they
bind to it when
it's on the membrane
membrane bound TNF
membrane bound soluble
and by binding TNF
it prevents it from
binding its receptor,
and therefore, the
pro-inflammatory
signaling is prevented.
Now, Etainercept,
which is a picture
of it here, only
binds the soluble.
It is nonetheless
effective in the
treatment of
rheumatoid arthritis.
Okay,
influximab first.
IV,
The patient
has to go to an
infusion center
about every eight
weeks to receive
the infusion.
It's eliminated.
Elimination is
undefined. It goes the
same way as any
protein by proteases.
Possibly it's
taken out in the
reticuloendothelial
system. It's got a nice
half-life, week,
week and a half.
And a quick onset,
less than a week,
and the duration
of action is
long, two to three
months, basically.
Binds both the
soluble and
the membrane-bound TNF.
And it's good for
lots of different
inflammatory diseases.
It's widely used.
Here's our rheumatoid
arthritis. here's
our psoriatic
arthritis and so on.
The adverse effects
are typical of the
biologic
immunosuppressants class
and we get some
hepatic infection risk
HBVTB reactivation
that's why we
have to check it
out in advance
see if the patient
was exposed to
either of those
infectious agents.
It is injectable
so local injection
site reactions,
and it is a
protein, hypersensitivity
reactions.
Etainercept now,
subcutaneously,
once or twice a week,
decent half
-lives, onset of
effect two to
three weeks,
and the full
effect usually
in about three months.
So as I said before
it binds a soluble
TNF and it's got
various uses here
and the adverse
effects are typical
of the class.
You learn them
once and just add
just remember that
all of them do
the same thing.
Adalimumab here is
the one that our
patient Mary decided
to take this is a fully
human monoclonal
antibody subcutaneously
once a week maybe
even once every other
week and the maximum
effect is in about
three months but
the onset is quicker
and I'm not going to
spend time talking
about these two
but you should be
aware that they're
around and they
are effective
for management of
rheumatoid arthritis
and they're subcute
Moving now to a
different cytokine, IL-6,
tocilizumab and
cerulamab are
actually IL-6
receptor antagonists.
And I put here information
on IL-6 in case
you're interested in
getting a sense of
this powerful pro
-inflammatory cytokine. Here
is a picture of the
IL-6 receptor, and
it can float around or
be attached, and here's
our monoclonal
antibody binding to it.
IV every four weeks, and
then, after this
loading dose,
sub-Q weekly or
every other week,
depending on the
patient's body weight.
And it's got a
decent half-life, up
to a couple of weeks,
at steady state.
IL-6 receptor
antagonist, it's easy
to remember, because
that's its class.
Soluble and membrane
-bound receptors.
We always think
about receptors
as being attached
to a membrane,
but some of them are not.
So reduction in
cytokine production.
So that reduces the
pro-inflammatory
effect of IL-6
cytokine. It can be used
monotherapy. It was
tried in clinical
trials as monotherapy,
and it can be
combined with
mesotrexate. and it can be
given to pediatric
arthritis patients.
Now, interestingly,
it was found to be
useful in patients with
COVID-19 who were
hospitalized, receiving
supplemental oxygen,
mechanical ventilation,
and so they started
using it for that,
and it helped improve
patient outcomes.
so clearly IL-6 is
associated with that
clinical picture
infection risk
neutropenia thromocytopenia
liver enzymes
LDL GI perforation
oh that's a new one
isn't it GI perforation
we haven't seen
that with this group
of drugs before
so that's a kind of a
takeaway drug-specific
effect also this increase
in LDL-C so that's
cholesterol increase
in blood cholesterol
of the low-density
lipoprotein type and
it's not recommended
in pregnancy and that
takes us to a couple
of different approaches
these are also
biologic DMARDs about
accept and rituximab
they don't work the
same we'll talk about
that just to remind
you about T cells
and B cells T cells
are antigen presentation
plus co-stimulation
are required to
activate the T cell.
Then it differentiates,
releases pro
-inflammatory cytokines,
instigates the
inflammatory cascade,
and also it will
activate the Th1
cells and the B cells,
CD8 T cells,
and T cells are very,
very important. And
B cells, when activated,
will differentiate
into memory and
plasma cells. The
plasma cells make the
antibodies, and we're
talking about
autoantibodies here now,
and they will draw
complement activation.
This is just a
picture of the various
ways that T cells
are activated and
differentiate into
these different types.
You don't have
to memorize that.
These are, here we
have our B cell. This
is the one in the,
the pre, the pre, what
am I saying? The
progenitor. And now we
get these pre B
cells and now they go
into the periphery,
and they differentiate
into the plasma cells
and memory cells.
CD20, and that's
why I went to
all of this
trouble here of
reminding you
about the process.
CD20 is a cell surface
antigen expressed
on all B cells
beginning with
the pro-B cell stage
through its terminal
differentiation
to plasma cells.
Basically that.
Anti-CD20 therapeutics,
so this is the
drug we're talking
about now, they were
originally developed
for the treatment
of B cell cancers,
but they have been
found, rituximab
in particular, has
been found to be
really useful in the
management of many
autoimmune diseases.
So we're going to be
talking about CD20
as the target and
remembering that blocking
CD20 is going to be
blocking the function
of all of that group
of B cells. And
this is just a
reminder about the
process. I'm not
going to go through
it to any great
extent. And this
is the T-cell
activation section.
And here we have
our B-cells.
Okay, let's talk
about Abadicep now.
Abadicep is a
CTLA fused to IgG.
So it's a fusion protein.
CTLA. Let's
talk about the
function of CTLA.
It's right here.
This is a co-receptor,
CD28 is a co-receptor.
The T cell
gets activated,
I should say, when
the APC presents
antigen to the T
cell at the T cell
receptor here, that
starts a process.
It is not enough
to activate the T
-cell with just this
one interaction.
This co-receptor
signal needs to occur.
CD28 on the T-cell
binds to CD80 and
CD86 on the antigen
-presenting cell,
and you may have
heard of it as B7.
And this will now
activate the T-cell.
once the t-cell has
been activated there's
like as happens
with everything in
our body naturally
in the normal healthy
body there is a
regulatory mechanism so
ctla gets expressed
on the t-cell binds
to the cd8086 with
greater affinity than
the cd28 and that
will stop the process
It's a regulator.
Now let's look
at abatacept.
And this illustrator
has shown
that abatacept,
which is CTLA, looks
like CTLA here
on the T cell.
Abadicept, which
has high affinity
for the CD8086, will
out-compete CD28.
And what happens?
That prevents the
co-stimulatory signal
from occurring.
That's Abadicept.
Prevents T cell
activity by preventing
its activation.
That's a pretty elegant
mechanism, isn't it?
IV every four weeks,
then subcutaneously,
so again with the
IV loading dose
followed by subcutaneous
maintenance dose.
Pretty long half-life,
once weekly.
And here's the
mechanism that I already
described. It also
has been tried
with or without
methotrexate and has
been found to be
efficacious both ways.
Generally, adding
methotrexate to
anything increases
the efficacy.
So, pediatrics,
psoriatic, graft
-versus-host disease,
which I'll just
briefly mention
once we get to the
immunosuppressants
lecture. and
adverse effects.
Well, serious
infections, obviously.
Respiratory infections,
local injection
site, overall safety
is comparable to
the TNF inhibitor.
So that's good news.
And we don't give
it together with
other strong
immunosuppressants.
So let's talk now
about rituximab.
This is the anti-CD20
monoclonal antibody.
It induces depletion
of the peripheral B
cells. Remember what
B cells express CD20.
So we deplete the
peripheral B cells.
They can't produce
those autoantibodies.
And it happens by
three mechanisms.
Complement gets
activated, so that
causes complement
-mediated cytolysis.
The antibody, here's
rituximab here,
this is the FC
portion. That will
draw an NK cell, a
natural killer cell,
and that will
produce this antibody
-dependent cellular
cytotoxicity.
So it sends in
its granules
and produces
lysis, cell lysis.
And then a theoretical
mechanism is
the actual activation
of apoptosis.
So believe these
two are clear
and this one is
still relatively
theoretical. It's
possible though.
And this is where
B cell depletion
idea comes in.
It just destroys
the B cells. It
depletes them.
IV, and we talked
about the mechanism of
action. The use, it's
got so many uses.
In terms of rheumatoid
arthritis, it's
patients really who
have not responded
well to methotrexate
in an anti-TNF therapy
or patients who have
a lymphoproliferative
disorder because
that's what
rituximab was originally
designed to treat.
And I put the
other uses here.
And it's the usual
adverse effects that we
see with all of them,
including reactivation
of hepatitis B virus,
and something called
PML, progressive multifocal
leukoencephalopathy,
and this is related
to something called
the JC virus, which
hangs out in the brain.
So if the JC virus
gets reactivated
because of the
presence of rituximab,
it can lead to
this progressive
multifocal
leukoencephalopathy.
These are very important
adverse effects
to remember.
And I just need
a little recap
table here of the
biologic DMARDs.
Which brings us to
our last set of drugs,
the JAK inhibitors,
Janus kinase inhibitors.
Inhibiting them
prevents the signal
transduction of numerous
cytokines. the Janus
kinase receptors are
cytokine receptors.
Well I'm only asking
you to remember the
tofacitinib which is
the prototype of the
group. The others
are pretty much the
same and they're all
equally efficacious.
In this figure
here's the cytokine
coming in to
the receptor.
Here's our Janus
kinase hanging
out here at the
receptor. You
see the receptor
is dimerized.
The cytokine
occupies the receptor
and activates the
Janus kinases. They're
kinases so they
phosphorylate. So
they phosphorylate
here on the
intracellular portion
of that receptor.
And something
called STATS,
these are signal pathway
transcription activators,
bind to these
phosphates, which
activates them, and
then they dimerize,
and move into the
nucleus and induce
transcription of
various proteins,
including pro
-inflammatory proteins.
This picture here
shows that tofacitinib
acts internally,
intracellularly,
to block the activity
of Janus kinase.
oral, oral,
CYP3A4. If you see
TINIB, whether
it's for rheumatoid
arthritis or
any other use,
think CYP3A4. And
when you think
CYP3A4, think
drug interactions.
And it's got a pretty
short half-life.
So it's different
than we've seen
with the others,
but it is oral. It's
convenient for the
patient to take.
Use limited to
patients who have not
adequately responded
to or are intolerant
of TNF inhibitors.
So the TNF inhibitors
go first. I mentioned
the COVID before.
Okay, this has a bunch
of potential adverse
effects that need
to be monitored. And
also we need to be
thinking about, is the
patient going to be a
good candidate for this
drug so it can all
of them can cause
thrombosis so thinking
about patients who already
have a history of
cardiovascular disease
whether it's myocardial
infarction or
****** or patients even
with ischemic heart
disease patients with
a history of thrombi
this extra thrombosis
effect can lead to
these serious cardiovascular
adverse events
including pulmonary
embolism and these
are all potentially
deadly higher rate
of all-cause mortality
in patients who
are 50 years old or
older who have at
least one cardiovascular
risk factor.
Takeaway. That's
a takeaway
adverse effect point.
And this is what
we expect with any
powerful immunosuppressive
infection.
Gastrointestinal
perforation can occur with
this. We saw that
also with tocilizumab.
Avoid in pregnancy
and combining
with other powerful
immunosuppressants
is contraindicated.
And strong, or moderately
strong, either one,
CYP3A4 inducers
or inhibitors
is contraindicated.
So this is a bunch
of other cytokine
inhibitors that are
used clinically.
No, you don't have
to memorize this.
It's here to put you
in the picture of
what's going on in
the treatment of
autoimmune and
inflammatory diseases.
If you care to look
at it, not memorize,
you'll see many
similarities between
the drugs and
between the groups.
So check your knowledge.
Annabelle is a 52
-year-old woman with
rheumatoid arthritis
diagnosed one year ago.
Her current RA regimen
consists of methotrexate
at maximal dose,
infliximab, and
prednisone because
of recurrent
disease flares.
Annabelle agrees to
discontinue the infliximab
and begin treatment
with a cytokine receptor
antagonist that blocks
the actions of a
cytokine found in high
concentrations in the
synovium and serum of
RA patients. She will
receive intravenous
induction therapy with
the biologic drug,
followed by maintenance
biweekly self-administered
sub-Q injections.
Monitoring includes
complete blood count,
liver function
tests, and signs and
symptoms of infection.
What is the drug?
So what are the clues.
Cytokine receptor
antagonist
and biologic drug.
There's only one that
fits that description.
And that is tocilizumab.
And these answers
are all at the end
of this PowerPoint.
So in summary, we have
these three groups,
the conventional
synthetic DMARDs,
biologic DMARDs, which
are proteins, and the
targeted small molecule
synthetic DMARDs.
I'm not going to read
this to you. You can
read it to yourself,
and I hope that it
will give you clues
to what's important to
remember about these
drugs. between the key
points and the summaries
and the charts.
And here's a
summary of all
of these different ones.
And the therapy
combinations,
therapy options,
and our answers
to our questions.
And that completes the
lectures on the DMARDs.